hop out of bed for some eggs bunny side
up and then wage backyard garden warfare
with the pollinator bebop because it's
episode 55 of loot emerge from the
shadows and learn to harness them with
the Shadow Puppets mug and once you've
mastered hand manipulation take a crack
at a full body challenge on an
inflatable obstacle course from
inflatable you can rent them for parties
festivals or just because they're
awesome and they have everything from
Hidden Temple courses to Robo rampage
after you've had yourself a whale of a
time use these whale knives to prepare
dinner but if you find a spider in the
salad bust out this spider catching gun
to keep it from scrabbling away speaking
of Scrabble why not add some alphabetic
flair to your living room with the scrub
a light set which you can use to spell
whatever you want mark wherever you've
been on earth with the scratch map and
watch as your travels change the world
or at least the color of the world map
if you get thirsty on your journeys grab
a zing water bottle which features a
built-in fruit press so you can add some
fruity zest to whatever you're drinking
but no matter what you do don't forget
sticky notes do not be afraid to learn
some Japanese with the jinmenken haunted
school escape board game the g-men kid
is a Japanese monster dog with a human
face and you need to collect various
items from around the school before he
catches you if you end up in the school
cafeteria take a break from running for
your life and enjoy a personalized
chocolate pizza made from Belgian
chocolate select from one of six
different flavors and personalize the
message plaque in the middle making it a
great item to bring to someone's
birthday and since it's their birthday
you might as well give them the
neverending birthday card which once
opened plays a birthday jingle
continuously for at least 3 hours even
if it's ripped up submerged underwater
or set on fire
after all that annoying music the adults
might want to sink into a gin and tonic
and then trick their brains into
perceiving fluid motion with the
busybody optical illusion toy based on a
zoetrope the busybody lets you pose a
number of mannequins placed around a
mirror and then create your own
real-life animated gif or Jif by giving
it a spin when they've run so much
they've worn out their shoes grab a pair
of these sneaker soaps which come in
styles from adidas superstar soaps to
Air Jordans then when you get sick of
the air head to the ocean with deep sea
sand art an interactive piece of art
that has undersea mountains that form
before your very eyes open your eyes
underwater after attaching the go fish
cam and get high quality footage of a
thing caught on your fishing line it has
night vision and connect to your phone
so you can see what's going on down
there but if you don't check the footage
then the fish both is and isn't caught
just like this Schrodinger cat mug to be
sure your dinner does exist sign up for
the carnivore Club which sends you a box
of artisanal meat every month like south
african dried meats or canadian maple
jerky eat your meat inside the gays box
a resealable cover that can act as both
a gazebo and a carport now that you have
a garage it's time to buy a home a
spaceship home made by gnome the
spaceship home is built from three
modules is eco-friendly and is largely
automated so if you ever wanted to live
in a spaceship this is probably your
best chance though it is missing
something is an inflatable bathtub just
make sure you place it far away from
your Frankenstein light switch because
if I let you get electrocuted people are
gonna say I'm cold hearted Pluto and as
always thanks for watching
you
is an inflatable bathtub